[Music]
a new level of climate insanity taking
root while prices at the pump crush the
american people the international energy
agency has put out this ridiculous
10-point plan to help reduce global oil
demand ready some other absurd
suggestions include cities going car
free on sundays
traveling by train instead of flying and
only allowing people to drive private
cars
every other day so greg if you want to
go to san francisco i think a train
would be the best opportunity to do that
imagine how pleasant that would be on
amtrak just right across the country i'd
meet so many interesting people and
probably get killed by them none of
these draconian measures affect people
in the city it's just to punish the
rubes in the sticks and the suburbs city
most city folks don't need cars none of
this absurd austerity has an effect on
them they're basically forcing people
that they look down on to solve the
problems that they cause time to create
a 10-point austerity plan
for people who live in the city no more
pizza by the slice right huh that's
costly they have to buy it in bulk you
can only use food delivery
once a week
you can you can have to cook at home the
whole time you know you get you should
get paid more in if you live in the
cities we need to slash the salaries and
use that money to explore alternative
energy so the salary should come back
down to maybe what people make in the
suburbs we do know that there's more
crime in the cities but i think to save
on costs we need to shut off the nine
the 911 phone service during the
weekends perhaps the hours between 4 and
7 a.m during the week i imagine the kind
of savings
imagine dana well it's amazing how the
administration will turn themselves into
a pretzel in order to avoid exploring
for more oil and gas it is just absurd
and truly if you want to
invest more in alternative energies you
know who mostly is doing that the oil
companies
i mean that's they have the money to do
it look at any of their portfolios
they're they are doing that they are
doing that and that is what they are
doing
that was a very caramel apparently
americans don't like austerity a lot of
us don't know what that word means but
we don't like having to reduce
our freedoms in order to sacrifice for
something after we've sacrificed so much
over the last three years with kovid
true
and judge so what do you think
so i was watching bill maher this
weekend and he had on obama's former
energy secretary who has an organization
a think tank with bush's former energy
secretary and they have something called
the green real deal which they feel is
this consensus-building approach to
taming climate change now they agree
that climate change is man-made all the
the normal democratic platform
points but they are emphasizing using
our natural gas capabilities and using
nuclear energy to help us get to the
place that we all say we want to go in
2050. and it feels like those kind of
conversations when people are not going
to not take their car on sunday or
whatever it is are more realistic and
i think that people can decide to do
those things themselves but when you
hear these things from the people up on
high who are probably not living that
way themselves it just aggravates people
so
what is this agency is this a un thing
i never heard the iea the iea yeah no
it's an international yeah
so they associate it with the united
nations
i don't think so it was started by old
macdonald well then where do they come
off telling us to stop drinking
but but but here's the thing i mean it's
mimicking what the democrats want to do
and the totalitarian instinct is very
strong with the democrats they got used
to it and they feel bad govern's almost
over i think it's over coven's almost
over and now they want to tell us what
to do and here's the thing the one that
really gets my attention is they want us
to use a night train instead of a plane
now i can see myself coming back home
chicago or a speech coming into penn
station at three in the morning
you know what now i can be a crime
statistic but they won't be using any
airplane fuel i mean come on stupid oh
so stupid how do you spell that
s-c-o-o-p-i-d all right coming up chaos
it's spring break cops looking to crack
down after a surge in shootings hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else